Oh God
what did you do Oh God
I can't escape it yeah chase Hudson aka
little honey just can't escape charlie
D'Amelio very crazy the tic-tock stars
announced their split in April but this
week
Thomas petrol chases roommate and
co-founder of the hype house pulled off
one epic prank on chase with the help of
his ex well sort of we've got a lot of
pictures of Charlie yeah Thomas
wallpapered chases entire room with a
pic of Charlie like her face is legit
everywhere on the walls on his TV on his
bed I'm pretty sure I even saw it on the
ceiling fan people I do really dumb like
that jokes that's my whole thing but
don't worry guys Thomas ran the whole
thing by Charlie and her sister Dixie to
see cold so I figured I'd show her we're
just on it mean maybe hilarious
definitely way they just having fun with
that so how did chase react Oh God
what did you do oh god I can't escape
this holy my bad room
seriously Bravo Thomas
[Applause]
and one photo yes for everything so how
do you like it I take any of these dogs
naturally Thomas it up tick tock to
share the prank I'm like the dad of the
house like I everyone knows that I just
do tick talking stuff because it's fun
so Jace how do you like your new gift
and so did chase he shared this clip
writing Thomas covered my entire room
with pictures of Charlie brah I'm weak
Charlie and chase announced the news of
their breakup on Instagram Charlie
writing that it hurts but they are still
close friends he's a really really sweet
boy as for Chase he said samesies
writing that they will always have love
for each other that they will always be
friends and he's beyond grateful and
blessed have spent time with her they're
just like off in our own little fairy
land it was cute their split came just
months after they first started hanging
out the first it was just thing yeah
this is like fun poking jokes and a
little bit of flirting here and there
and then he really took off later in
February little Heidi told ET they were
exclusive but not officially
boyfriend-girlfriend
I'm taking it as slow as humanly
possible okay before I pop the question
okay but we are very exclusive and very
into each other earlier this month et
learned Charlie and her sister Dixie
actually left the hype house because it
was turning more into a business than a
creative space and Charlie told ET she
has her own career plans in mind is a
reality show something that you guys
would do I mean yeah definitely
something that would be super fun people
kind of see what goes on when we're not
just posting which I feel like no one
really gets to see but people are always
talking about how they think our family
dynamic
cool like they love it illegalized so
that's super size I mean it's really
whatever helps like us showcase what
we're really like
[Music]